many work all day others help
outside and inside the home no matter
what the situation is they take care of their
family and make sure they don't lack anything
if they the parents accompany them to learn about
the story of
watermelons then i am an official watermelons
with  department of las vegas' metro
for me to be a father is something that
24 hours a day 7 days a week i
work he came home tired and is
working all day but my children
and they are happy to see me i have to be
ready for
and  entertain them take care of them bathe
them feed them
the father always worries about my
children and I am always thinking about them
we have four children and we have
two
girls two boys
in 98
and two years is a balance because as he
has a professional with an officer
who  I am in the way of resources for
others also I always think in the same way
how I can give mass a better life
my children do not worry as I am a
police officer but I always have to
tell them  that
to return home
my life ends with them
that is the best part of me
and I teach them that they rules
have respect for us but
first of all I respect their mother I respect other
students their teacher respect the
police when they see a police tell her
hi
so i'm a dad i teach them
to treat
diego and i start to find out how
everyone's day was it's very funny because they
all want this attention at the same
time i
give them attention because i think
they know i'm there no more  I'm
working and now it's time for
them sometimes we play outside and I
'm playing with his pond on the walls and
we play music we're outside
playing with him but what I like
about writing with my family is what
our children do together  and
daughters are always looking at
what we do not do what we say to
each other how we speak we are the
example they are
going to treat their family they are going to learn
the good and the bad I do not know everything I continue to
learn  giving how to be a father but of
course
I want to be the best father
I can eat
and the bad thing that I have the
best life I have had reported for
him is nothing in Spanish
natalia lancellotti